can the new M2 Max MacBook Pro beat out
an I9 3080 TI Windows Beast of a laptop
well today we will find out because
we're to be testing everything from
benchmarks to real world productivity
with video editing photo editing 3D
rendering and much more now believe it
or not but this MSI crater
z16p costs more money than this MacBook
Pro now here is the full spec sheet side
by side you guys could see that it has
double the RAM and twice the storage but
if we spec up the MacBook the same way
it still costs a hundred dollars less so
this isn't some cheap Windows laptop it
is specced out to the max that 3080 TI
is expensive and has 16 gigs of
dedicated memory whereas the M1 Mac ship
has to share that 32 gigs with
everything now yes the CPU here is is
not a 13 gen those are not out yet but
we do have one on order it's going to be
coming soon so make sure you guys
subscribe but this is still a 14 core
processor compared to a 12 core and it
runs at up to 5 gigahertz compared to
3.7 on this one now it also comes with a
massive 240 watt power brick compared to
140 because this thing sucks down power
so we will also see how it does when we
unplug it now I also have to say that
the build quality is phenomenal this
thing feels like a Macbook it's made out
of metal there's very little Flex we
have a ton of ports multiple Thunderbolt
ports the keyboard also feels great and
although the trackpad is not as good as
apples it is still one of the best
Windows track pads out there the msi's
display is also very nice it has a high
resolution it is sharp it's also DCI P3
color accurate but the contrast levels
are no we're near as good and it has
more reflectivity because Apple's
anti-reflectivity Coatings are much much
better the display is also more vibrant
because it is mini LED now this also has
a higher refresh rate 165 hertz compared
to a 120 but unlike the MacBook it
doesn't have promotion where it can
scale down but one benefit is that it is
actually a touch screen which also is
why it has more reflectivity and with
that they actually have a really nice
pen with a lot of different uh
sensitivity pressure levels so if you
want to draw on it that is definitely a
benefit now Windows laptops are always
advertising they're high-end speakers
with Brands and this one seems to have a
good system so let's go ahead and
compare them
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
well while there's no denying that the
MSI gets loud there is no base and a lot
of the mints are lacking too whereas the
MacBook has those woofers that sound
absolutely amazing unbelievable for such
a laptop of this size and this is the
msi's 1080p webcam quality along with
the front facing microphones and this is
the MacBook Pro's 1080p webcam with its
studio quality microphones let me know
which one looks better and which one
sounds better down in the comment
section below now before I dive deep
into performance I gotta talk about the
best macsafe iPhone case I have ever
seen the magic stand k from our partner
K school not only is it surprisingly
slim and durable but it also comes with
a very strong 48 Magnet Max a Fring that
actually doubles as a stand just pull
out the ring to use it as a finger grip
or a stand for watching videos at any
angle between 40 and 120 degrees and the
best part is that it folds back
completely flush with the case so you
can still use it with your Maxim
Chargers and accessories so use the link
below to get 23 off your order today now
getting into performance I want to let
you know that our MSI is set to the best
performance mode and it is plugged in
while our MacBook is unplugged and the
first test that I want to do is an SSD
speed test and it looks like the msi's
2tb SSD is about 150 megabyte per second
faster in terms of read speed but the
MacBook is way faster in terms of write
speed I'm talking 2 300 megabytes per
second faster and it's only a one
terabyte and now let's run geekbench 5
and see what can have a difference we
get with such a massive clock speed on
the MSI and once again I reminded of the
old Intel days where even on geekbench
this system is ramping up its fans while
the MacBooks fans are completely shut
off alright well I was not expecting
this because the MacBook beat out the
MSI in both single core which I thought
it would as well as multi-core we have a
12 difference in single core and apple
did clock demon Max higher than the M1
Pro but in multi-core it also beat it
out now not by much it's just five
percent but it did now I'm excited to
see what we get in cinebench we're gonna
max out the CPUs but first I want to
test out web browsing and web-based
application performance using figma that
is brought to you by our partners at 500
designs now a lot of people use a
software and the first I'm going to do
is just zoom in over here see how smooth
everything is nice and smooth on the
MacBook let's go down here and see how
long it takes to load up some of these
images
little bit of glitchiness but pretty
much instant to load up these high
resolution photos let's zoom in
and right there as soon as I zoomed in
it was pixelated and then it refreshed
it let's test out the Windows laptop
plugged in here
also a little bit of glitchiness but
pretty quick how about down here
definitely a lot longer that was about
three seconds or so to load up that high
resolution image compared to I think
it's practically instant over here and
now I'm going to export these 12 high
resolution layers into a website and
that took a minute and 35 seconds on the
Mac let's see how long it takes on the
Windows all right the MSI took two
minutes to do this so even though
geekbench was just slightly faster this
is 27 faster in real life web-based
applications and it's on battery and for
simple web browsing the MacBook is 35
faster and more responsive now I really
want to compare the graphics but first
we have to push these CPUs to their
limits so I also have some Hardware info
right here wow the MSI is running at 82
watts compared to 33 on the Mac we hit
96 degrees Celsius on MSI right there
the fans are ramping up but our Mac fans
are still off and it's running way
cooler this MSI does have a beefy Vapor
chamber cooling system but it is still
slowing itself down we're now running at
about three gigahertz in order to keep
itself from getting too hot because just
sucks a lot of power now it's been about
seven minutes and things have settled
down so I want to do a thermal test here
the MSI is hot 52 degrees right there on
the exhaust in the center here 47
and if we look at it the hottest spot 53
there if you guys could see it's
actually blowing all over the MacBook
heating up that whole side which
otherwise would be as cool as this my
goodness now the Mac 41 right there the
hottest
40 39
compared to
52 dang now they're actually running at
about the same clock speeds which is
interesting but the MSI is using about
twice the power we had 62 watts compared
to 36 and of course the fans are blaring
compared to being pretty much silent on
the Mac which now just finished and we
have a winner and it is actually the MSI
14 694 compared to
13749 that is seven percent faster while
using almost twice the power and a lot
of fan noise and plugged in now I'm
excited for the 13 gen once again we
have the ordered so make sure you enable
your notifications and now it's finally
time to compare graphics performance
with that 3080 TI now I have the
wildlife extreme unlimited test here so
we have the same resolution it's off
screen so resolution differences won't
matter alright wow that is kind of low
you know it really frustrates it's me
when you have high performance mode
turned on in Windows but then in Nvidia
settings they have battery boost enabled
and then in MSI settings they have Smart
auto mode enabled and that's limiting
your performance so let's shut that off
and let's run that again all right well
that is definitely better this time we
have
119.6 FPS for the 3080 TI but the
MacBook actually beats it out
150.8 that is 26 faster and before I
change the settings the Mac was 40
faster now the 3080 TI that's in here
it's not the full on desktop or super
high wattage one they do cap the wattage
so it doesn't get too hot and with the
M1 Max the 3080 TI definitely would have
smoked it but with the M2 Max Apple
actually added a lot more cash a lot
more tlb memory which was a limitation
before and for our gaming loads it's
actually really fast now of course we
don't have a lot of games for Mac now
I'm running this without the power cable
plugged in because I'm curious about
this
and we have a score of wow okay
4627 and a half frames per second from
120. now the MacBook is five and a half
times faster because it doesn't lose
performance when it's unplugged now
we've seen this for many years now with
these high-end Nvidia graphics cards
even with Windows and high performance
mode I have enabled and all of the
Nvidia stuff disabled for power
throttling and MSI stuff disabled it
still really throttles the graphics
because that graphics card sucks a ton
of juice and it needs this cable to be
plugged in but now let's let the Nvidia
graphics card shine with blender 3D
rendering I have Opti X enabled which
means that it's going to use the ray
tracing cores to do this that's
incredibly fast and something that the
Mac doesn't have oh my goodness this
thing is flying now the M2 Max is way
better faster than before close to twice
as fast but the nvd card took
29.6 seconds compared to a minute and
four seconds that is more than twice as
fast so still way faster even though
Apple made really great improvements
just make sure they have a power outlet
next to you and you're plugged in or
else it gets incredibly slow now I'm
going to get into photo editing using
Lightroom which can use both a CPU and
the GPU and for some reason this screen
looks like it's in a force HDR mode but
I'm not gonna mess with it Lightroom has
a ton of cool AI features so I'm going
to test out the sky detection right
there you guys saw that was a second or
even less super quick less test out the
Windows laptop
all right about three seconds so three
times longer and that's probably because
of the neural engine built into the M2
Max I have all 50 of these 42 megapixel
raw images selected and let's go ahead
and Export them the MSI switching
between a CPU and GPU maxing those out
while the Mac looks like doing very
similar things but it's hammering on the
GPU both these are fast but the Mac is
faster taking 39 seconds compared to 51.
now neither of these machines throttle
actually well I guess this one slows
down slightly over some time so if
you're doing 500 photos which is what I
did the last time I edited my personal
photos well you're gonna be looking at
maybe six minutes it's roughly nine
minutes or so and I can't believe that
the Mac was faster even with that Nvidia
graphics card and should you be so
unlucky not to have a power outlet I
have to run it took a minute 29 seconds
compared to 39 so the macbook's two and
a half times faster and a shocking me
it's been done the whole time we're
still at 70 battery life through all
this setup of these apps all these
benchmarks and tests that is why a lot
of people buy a Mac and now let's get
into video editing with DaVinci Resolve
18 which is really well optimized for
both systems now the first thing I want
to throw at it is very heavy noise
reduction because this needs a ton of
raw horsepower and you can't improve it
using encoders or decoders or any other
kind of specialized Hardware as you guys
could see the MacBook is averaging 13
frames per second playing this back
which is a great Improvement compared to
the previous one but the 3080 TI is
averaging let's see it's going between
18 19 20. looks like it settled at 19. I
thought 19 but now it's slowing down
because the fans kicked up meaning the
system got hot now I'm glad I let this
play longer because I was going to call
it 13 versus 19
uh but now we're running at 13 14.
13. I can't believe it it's actually
pretty much the same our Mac has its
fans at the lowest speed possible as you
guys could see and it's running cool and
now we're down to about 12 11 12 frames
per second wow I guess a 3080 TI is
meant for a much thicker laptop or of
course a desktop but the performance is
practically the same which I didn't
expect and now I have a five minute 6K
Blackmagic raw project here I didn't
want to go too easy because these are
high in laptops but as far as raw codex
this is on the easier side both play it
back perfectly and if we take a look at
our Graphics usage it's only 24
we have a lot of overhead here but on
the Mac wow it's actually using less I
did not expect that that means that the
Mac might actually have more raw power
for processing effects and color grades
Luts that kind of stuff now what happens
if we unplug
this thing from Power
okay I'm going to reset this it was
playing back perfectly
no
no 14 15 frames per second
instead of 24 so it literally cannot
process this raw footage
because the system slows down the
graphics so now it's maxing out the
graphics card and there's nowhere near
enough performance I honestly had much
higher expectations for this 3080 TI but
let's plug this sucker back in and we
are going to export this let's hit run
and I expect it to be close because the
raw performance in the playback in the
GPU usage was very similar so let's take
a look we're at 57.5 frames per second
for encoding but the Mac is at
133 and it is done it that is
legitimately way faster this is my first
time testing resolve I've been doing
Final Cut
that is incredible 55 seconds compared
to 2 minutes and 40 seconds that is
literally three times faster that is
insane and if we try the MSI on battery
it's showing us 15 and a half minutes
compared to 55 seconds on battery you
know what Apple
We complain a lot about incremental
updates and ssds and stuff but when you
put something like this head to head two
machines
similar price tag actually this one's
3500 because I didn't load up on Ram or
whatever and you see how the real world
performance Compares not just geekbench
you know or some Benchmark it absolutely
blows your mind and then the rest of the
high quality design trackpad speakers
display I don't know how anybody else
can compete now let's hope that the new
13 gen Intel and the new RTX graphics
cards can step it up because they really
need to if you guys want to buy one of
these use that YouTube shopping feature
down below let me know your thoughts on
all of this click that Circle about to
subscribe if this video brought you
value or entertainment check out one of
those and I'll see you in the next video
foreign